we begin with a developing story
protesters have reportedly stormed and
set fire to government offices in
kazakhstan's largest city almaty the
violence comes as mass demonstrations
over surging fuel prices in kazakhstan
entered a fourth day
last night thousands marched in defiance
of a curfew and ban on mass gatherings
police they used tear gas and stun
grenades
after crowds refused to disperse
windows were smashed and roads blocked
the president has declared a state of
emergency in two regions and said some
price caps on fuel would be reinstated
the central asian country's cabinet was
earlier fired in a bid to head off the
unrest
let's return now to our top story and
get the very latest from emily sherwin
in moscow and emily just to remind our
viewers what we're talking about here is
these tensions over soaring energy
prices escalating in kazakhstan we've
been having some reports now in the past
hours of police using tear gas stun
grenades on protesters trying to storm
government offices in almaty just walk
us through what we've been seeing
well today there are continuing protests
in kazakhstan across the entire country
apparently thousands of people have come
out in different regions of the country
in uh the biggest city in in kazakhstan
in almaty which is the former capital
several thousands of people are on the
streets and there have been reports as
you say of clashes between protesters
and police
of police
using stun grenades of protesters in
several cases actually attacking
the police and it doesn't seem that the
authorities have control of the
situation
they introduced yesterday
a state of emergency in several regions
including in
almaty and in the surrounding regions
but that hasn't helped it seems there's
also the internet seems to be being
blocked in large swathes of the country
potentially to stop the protesters from
coordinating but that doesn't seem to
have have kind of calmed things down and
now we're seeing um the uh the sydney
administration and almaty has been
stormed
several other
official buildings it seems have gone up
in smoke
at least judging from pictures on social
media
so things aren't calming down it seems
so what comes next then emily because i
mean the government has already resigned
well it's hard to know this these
protests started over the weekend about
a big hike in the prices on lng on a
rather liquefied petroleum gas lpg which
many people use in their cars as fuel
the government before was subsidizing
prices on that and then they liberalized
the market and we saw prices double at
the beginning of the year people were
very angry initially their demands were
economic but over the last few days
the government has been kind of playing
catch-up so initially
they said there was nothing they could
do about the prices then they went back
on that and they actually
slashed the prices down halfway once
again that didn't calm down protesters
now we've seen the the government
resigning but many people see that kind
of as a symbolic concession
because mostly it's the president who
controls uh the country and that's why
people uh have continued to take to the
streets
i can't really imagine there being big
uh political concessions going forward i
think probably we're likely to see a
crackdown
emily sherwin with the view from moscow
uh telling us what's going on on the
ground there in kazakhstan thank you for
your reporting emily